alright thanks so yeah I'm going to talk
about image analysis with scikit-learn
and PI spark working together and how
these form a use case for anaconda
cluster which is a tool for deploying
clusters on ec2 or digital ocean or
other cloud providers even whoa sorry
about that on so talking about PI spark
and scikit-learn in Psych it image so
psychic learned in psych it image or
applied to each image in this image
search engine and PI spark is used to do
joins and clustering among all images
together so there's part of it that
could be run and tested on the local
machine that's the scikit-learn in Psych
it in and then there's part of it that
uses the cluster and PI spark and so
what the gold is of this image analysis
project is to line up similar images so
if you had a historical image it look
like that you should be able to line it
up with a obvious cated version like
that and so I used a faces data set from
that's used in face detection training
and did the code on the left to
obfuscate the photos and then see if I
could find the the the fuzz ified
version in the original with the search
engine oh
so here are some helpful links for this
demonstration there's the github
repository that's public and I can walk
over to that that's right here at
continuum I otach in the J analyzer and
that has the PI spark and so I can learn
Python files it has a run helper file
for submitting the codes to the cluster
and it has an I Python notebook and this
presentation and you can also view the
ipython notebook on NB viewer as a
read-only version so basically the steps
of the image analysis example are to put
a lot of images from the face training
data set on HDFS the Hadoop distributed
file system using commands like this and
then to run measurements on each image
using pi spark to parallel lies the
embarrassingly parallel process of doing
psych learn measurements on each image
and then there's the clustering among
all images together that's done with PI
spark and then PI spark does joins and
various similarity matching to line up
similar images so to go through some of
the measurements that we're doing on
each image we're doing k-means which is
an unsupervised clustering algorithm and
there's a good documentation for the
function we're using from cycling right
here on the color quantization example
so they are starting with an original
image that has 96,000 unique colors and
using k-means to quantize the image into
64 representative called colors that are
more representative than 64 chosen at
random so that's kind of what we're
doing on each image is to do the k-means
on each each image with the fixed number
of centroids for each image and find out
what are the most representative colors
for those
images and then similar images can be
joined on those another thing we're
doing on each image with scikit-learn is
ward clustering and there's a really
good demo on this with the cycle urn
documentation but basically ward
clustering is an unsupervised
classification that finds pixels that
are similar in color but also tends to
prefer clusters that are contiguous in
space so that's why it's selecting out
regions like the face that are in that
are a distinct color in different
regions of the hair that are different
colors and what we do with this and this
image search engine is to take the
geometries of those clusters and hash
them in a scale independent way so that
we can find shapes that are similar
between different images even if maybe
the grayscale changed or the lighting
changed and then another thing we're
working on on each image is perceptive
hashes which is basically to convert an
image to grayscale and then encoded as
one if the pixels value is greater than
the mean grayscale or zero if less than
and there's a good blog about that on
hacker factor walking through taking
this original image sampling it down to
64 pixels and then calculating the
average color and then constructing a 10
bit array on to indicate whether each
pixel is greater than the mean and then
finally writing that out as a hash so
that's how we're using perceptive hash
here on and there's different ways you
can control its specificity by by
controlling how much you down sample
right here and how much of the image you
put into the hash
like if you do just partial images or
the full thing and we've experimented
with doing the full image or doing it in
chunks as well and so what you get out
of that function on each image is a
dictionary that looks like this so well
a tuple I should say the first is the
file name it came from and in the
dictionary of all the measurements on
the image that are numpy arrays each one
of them so we can by persisting this
these dictionaries in in a spark a
resilient distributed data set we can
subsequently map them and do whatever we
want with them check them and use them
for finding patterns among images
together and so that code that we've
seen there to make those measurements on
each image can also be run on your local
machine just using this I can't learn
stuff so you can run it on one image and
so this sort of sets up the
configuration for those different
clustering algorithms and how many
clusters to take on how how much down
sampling to do and then you get out that
same dictionary we just looked at so
that's pretty helpful when you're
developing code with PI spark is to
develop it in a way that each function
that you're going to map can be tested
locally outside of the setup of pi spark
so then after mapping through the images
and calculating those those image
measurement dictionaries for all the
images we do a k-means on all the images
together and there's some code in here
related to that basically we have done
our own k-means function rate here using
redo mapping the distance function and
then reducing by the closest distance
and I did it myself here rather than
using the ML live k-means because i also
wanted to keep track of hashes within
each k-means cluster to provide a sort
of secondary classification so to
provide the ability to join based on on
cluster and a hash from a perceptive
hash or a ward cluster and so this gives
an example of some of the what we can
end up from after that is a lot of
different lookups it look like this like
a hash from either a perceptive hash or
a ward cluster or on and on a file name
or this hash could be a cluster from the
k-means of all images together so that's
what searched up high does is assembling
all those flat lists and then the the
main part of the searching is to take
some new hashes the candidate hashes and
the old hashes and join them together
and so you might have the this shows the
old image the original from one source
and the new image has the same hash in
it this is a hash of a partial image and
a different file name so we end up with
a lot of tuples that look like that and
need to group by the hash and do a sort
of vote count so that's what it looks
like after you've if you've joined on a
hash and you have two votes for that to
two different file names that you that
had that hash in it and so this is an
example of how you would do that kind of
vote counting in PI spark so we start
with what we had before the the join
that creates joining the old hashes to
the new hashes on
on a key and then we have the group by
key so that makes the key be the hash
and then an iterable as the second item
X 1 and we can iterate through those and
find which file name had the most
occurrence which file name matched up
with it the the most and reduced by that
count keys function and end up with
something like this so this shows for a
particular candidate image that this the
it did find the best the original from
the original folder and it had these
other matches that didn't match enough
to be the top voted one when I think a
lot of those extraneous other matches
are related to the background of these
photos all being the same so to go over
the devops details they're actually
pretty easy and that's the fun part of
this talk is how easy it is to build
something like this with anaconda
cluster and this sort of gives you an
overview to getting started with
anaconda cluster and there are three
basic steps for starting the cluster the
first time after you've installed
anaconda cluster with Conda on the first
step is to set up a provider's yeah mol
file so this is just a text file
configuration that says what is the
cloud provider is at ec2 or digital
ocean or another one the secret ID and
key for that cloud provider a key name
so when you have a cloud provider you
have a remote key and you have to
download that and when you download it
you should have a path to where you have
downloaded it so those are all related
to security of the cloud provider so
that's the first small configuration
file you need and then the second one
you need is specific to your particular
kind of cluster
you want to start so this one says this
is a profile for this for spark clusters
that I want to start and it links back
to the provider yam will file we just
created and said we want to do AWS east
on we want to have a two node cluster we
want to start with this machine image we
want to do a large instance type the
user by default is Ubuntu and these
plugins are different sort of managed
plugins by anaconda cluster that do a
lot of DevOps details that will save you
a lot of time particularly in this case
this plug-in spark yarn that sets up
yarn and HDFS and spark throughout the
cluster so and all the configuration
files for the cluster to talk to each
other and it also configures the ipython
notebook which is helpful for checking
the results and the overview on profile
setup has a little bit more about some
of the plugins and details you can put
in there so then the last step now that
we have our two config files and we have
anaconda cluster installed is to create
a cluster with with any name naming a
profile we've already created so that's
a yam will file that we have in the
anaconda cluster directory and then some
more things you might want to do with
anaconda cluster are to put some files
on the cloud so this command at the top
would put some filed up pie into the
temp directory and the target says do
that for all the nodes on the cluster on
this one is the same kind of idea but
it's pushing a whole directory of data
and it's only doing it to the head node
it starts a zero-based node numbers so
you can push to 0 comma 1 or a put to 0
comma 1 or just 0 for the head
another thing you can do with the
Anaconda cluster is get a file off the
cloud after you've created it so with
the get it's really important to use the
target because if you don't use the
target it defaults to getting it from
all machines and naming it by the same
file which doesn't usually make sense so
what you would typically have is
different things going on on each node
if you needed to do this and on each
node they might be called the same thing
but then when you retrieve them you want
to have them name something else
according to the note they came from
anaconda cluster uses condo remotely so
these on you just take a normal Conda
install a command and you put a cluster
in front of it and then it does it on
the cluster and installs all those
dependencies or can list what you have
installed and then this is the last
thing we do when we're ready to run is
to submit a python file with the screen
argument and then it will stream the
output as it's going and we can also run
any remote command on some or all of the
nodes so this is doing an LS on all of
the nodes of that directory you could
also do something like git clone some
repo and then CD into it and then
install it and you can get a list of all
the clusters that are running and that's
helpful because it has the IP addresses
and you need to take this head IP
address out and that's where the ipython
notebook is when you're looking for it
on you can also look at the metadata for
a specific cluster so while my spark
lustre was running it had this file
right here which is the actual cluster
file so we had the to configure
shins the provider and the cluster
profile but those are both general
because the closer profile is for any
spark cluster that would be started
under a profile like that whereas this
cluster actual cluster file that we're
cutting out in cluster D is the actual
cluster as it's created with IP
addresses and other identifiers so this
is the file you would want to transfer
to someone else on if you wanted them to
be able to also use that cluster so you
would transfer this file and you would
also have to transfer this key to them
and have them put it at the same place
or change this around to where they put
it on and then it should work for them
to do all the things on the cluster that
you can do and then finally you destroy
the cluster so it takes care of all the
instance creation and instant shut down
for you and the nice thing about how
it's done in anaconda cluster is you say
you want to destroy it and it asks you
for sure and then it just shuts it down
and you don't have to wait for it to go
through all the cycles of actually
shutting it down and gives you feedback
right away and you can close your laptop
and so so far I've just talked about PI
spark and notebook but there are a lot
of other plugins that can be managed
through the plugins in the cluster
profiles so that gives us an idea of the
tools we're using for this image
analyzer example and we can look at the
run helper to see how it uses a lot of
those commands that we just looked at so
we start out by installing Python image
library and numpy we have to get the
unzip to help with the the data files we
do this these remote commands to run a
batch script that does all the H the
Hadoop file system put commands and then
we put on the cloud these the the files
from the repository that are important
in Python and the configuration file and
then finally we stream the mapper code
that has the spark context in it and so
yeah so that installs everything
downloads the images run through the
measurements and does the searches and
everything and while it's running it's
helpful to check its output and the
Anaconda cluster sets up these helpful
URLs the ipython notebook you just have
to replace this with your head node IP
web HDFS is useful when you're doing
spark to check and see files are
appearing the web HDFS is just a web
browser of the Hadoop distributed file
system and then the yarn cluster monitor
basically tells you about the busyness
of the cluster whether it's taking all
the capacity or whether it's hung
waiting for something and those are all
configured automatically with anaconda
cluster and there's a full list of all
the surfaces like this in the
documentation and which port to find
them on and then after the model run I
made this ipython notebook which is in
the lead so it's in the repository and
also on MV viewer but basically this
walks through looking at some of the
results and and working with PI spark so
this uses the configure PI spark right
there with the spark context and then we
can look at the pickle files of results
like this is an example of measurements
on an image
and then if and scrolling down we can
see there's the little bit of code
around the vote counting and an example
vote counts dictionary and then finally
in here we do where we are loading
images from what string io from the hood
distributed file system and labeling
them and seeing if we got the right
match and in this batch I got all but
one of them correct with except for that
the that one and then finally at the
bottom it shows the complete
configuration that the model was run on
to produce these results and that's what
I've got any questions on Pais parkour
anaconda cluster
yeah Peter I was burning like what where
for those how you're doing images you
know you sort of came up with this
method to mess with their applications
where you know you would find in a while
security camera footage to match up with
some pictures I was thinking to just the
same person in different photos that are
not obfuscated adan purpose but just
represent different positions or
different photos on and I think that
this method of lining them up could be a
pretty robust for for the finding the
same person in different positions
because it doesn't rely on sort of like
wavelets like opencv were of identifying
a face specifically it's based on the
colors of the image and not really
finding faces specifically so it could
potentially line up some in inches on
the chain on a similar background so
there's some positives and negatives to
that
on on this group of like 50 images it
was taking a couple minutes it highly
depends on D what you resize all the
images to when you start yeah that's the
main and also on the how many perceptive
hashes you create because if you create
one perceptive hash for each image you
don't only match the full image but you
create a shorter list of things to join
in the end whereas if you fragment it up
and do a lot of perceptive hashes then
you end up with longer join operations
and I'd actually be curious to see how
maybe some different more pythonic tool
in place of pi spark works for this like
say taking a lot of what's already been
written in thinking about it a different
way maybe that's distributed or
something like that
44 anaconda cluster I think Travis can
answer that better than I can right now
we're primarily
um you could do there's also ipython
parallel so that's another plug-in
that's managed I think you can do it on
a bare metal machine and the main thing
you need is that a cluster configuration
file oh this this file so by create
getting to this end cluster metadata
file is how you could apply this to on a
bare metal cluster I have it's been a
while since I've been through the steps
on that but it can be done
it creates a spark cluster that can't
that has the yarn client and you can run
it in local mode or with a yarn client
thereafter
okay well I think that's everything so
now I think we're just going to do lunch
and but I don't know how long lunches
but I think we're all this is to go get
some and hopefully they'll be enough
shut up this time around thanks Peter
sure